In this lecture we're going to learn about
how we get a digital image into a computer.
For robotic vision, this is the essential
first step; we have to have the visual information
inside the computer, so that we can manipulate
it and eventually extract meaning from it,
so this is the essential first step.
Digital images today are really common, they're
everywhere. Through billions and billions
of images on Facebook and Flickr and shared
through applications like Instagram. There
are a few reasons why digital images are so
common today.
The first is that cameras are everywhere so
the opportunities to take pictures are enormous.
We have cameras in our phones, in our tablet
computers, in our laptops. A large number
of people are now starting to wear cameras
on their heads photographing everything that
they're seeing and experiencing, 24 by 7 perhaps.
The second reason why is that storage has
become so cheap. Low cost flash memory in
our phones and in our laptop computers and
terabytes of hard disk storage that you can
buy for relatively little money today. It
wasn't always this way. Ten years ago we were
making the transition from chemistry to digital
technology for picture taking.
In the bad old days of chemical imaging, we
had to expose a number of frames on our film;
we could never delete an image. Once the film
was full, we'd take it to the shop, we'd get
it developed and we'd get our pictures back
on paper. It was way less flexible. So what
we're going to do in this lecture is work
out and discuss how we get images from many,
many digital sources, images from perhaps
your photo library, perhaps from the web camera
on your computer, perhaps from the web and
getting those images into an environment where
we can begin to manipulate them.